good morning rich our DP how are you I'm
good I'm good
I'm through your Los Angeles week yeah
you know it's it's that for 24:15
wake-up call
I'll get you I don't care can we create
an alarm that actually sounds better
when you wake up the worst thing for me
is in this era of iPhone is if
somebody's ringtone is my alarm to do
and I it just it it's the most jarring
thing around like because you just think
of the worst possible moments when
somebody else's phone rings obviously
it's something I can get through I can
work through it but just for that split
moment it's something yeah I think we
need to come up with something that's
just a little more soothing to wake you
up so it's tough for you here the three
hours or earlier but if you hang for the
weekend the NFL games kicking off at na
and the Saturday Night Football games
kicking off at five o'clock it's just
awesome it's grabbing the Michigan Ohio
State game it has been troubling that's
gonna be like some 9 it's 9 a.m. 9 a.m.
kick 9 a.m. kick no it's great just get
it out of the way I can't say I did I
just got to get to it got to get to so
it works like the the early time een my
kids actually saw the World Series
because well up until you know the 10th
inning for half the games but first
pitch being 5 o'clock out here it's it's
great just great
have you been to Ohio State Michigan
I've never been to the horseshoe
obviously my last game I covered for the
Michigan daily was beause last game as
coach which was Michigan Ohio State at
home his last game was the Rose Bowl
where he called a fake punt on USC with
four minutes and change to go that
worked and got called back doodlee hold
that to this day I still haven't seen on
film and he threw his headset down and
nearly fell ass over teakettle not 15
more yards tacked on top of it Bonnie
Raitt his last game as coach at Michigan
he was a lot more relaxed that week than
he was any other
throughout the season and we realized
that he knew that at the time it was
gonna be his last game at Michigan he
kind of like took it all in it was great
but this is horrible like you got to you
got to win this one I think you know
when you say Michigan's back Michigan's
not back until you beat Ohio State
you're you're gonna be favored going
into this game I don't understand that I
don't understand it I know Michigan has
been better but anything that everybody
says to me this year here you know or I
get the high register like hey like this
is it right you know like I get that
higher register which I'm not a fan of
and so I might look anything that ails
Ohio State whether it's in their locker
room or in their offense or whatever's
going on in the back end of their
defense it will all go away in time for
kick and then it just comes town and
executing and yeah based on what we've
seen so far this year over the last six
weeks it does you know it looks like it
could be are you Dan very well could be
you know could you see Harbaugh coaching
in the NFL now his parents live next
door to him you know he sends his kids
over to their grandparents his
grandparents can watch his kids play in
his backyard from their window I mean
they're those are things that you know
we all look at athletes and coaches as
if they are just athletes and coaches
and not human beings first I think that
that is something that you can't
discount obviously someone throws a ton
of money at him and he loves the idea of
going back I don't know but right now I
just don't see it but if he doesn't beat
Ohio State like that can we not have
that conversation like patently
disappointing yes no other way to put it
like this is the year it should can he
wear out his welcome at Michigan I mean
what do you mean by that by not winning
yeah by not beating Ohio State I'm
relevant yeah I mean and they're there
they're playing better and they have a
better I think this is the year that
we're not going to have this
conversation
hmm well I wonder what happens you
finally beat it out of me I mean I'm
trying not to I'm trying not to say the
sort of stuff but I I don't think he
will wear his welcome out I just I just
don't what about John Harbaugh
reportedly on the Hudson right now
Ravens wouldn't it be amazing if rg3 or
Lamar Jackson is the one that
quote-unquote saves his job there it's
entirely possible that one of those guys
goes on and III know people would even
say well rg3 hasn't played in years it
looks like one of those two is going to
play this one that would be a tune in
factor if you said Lamar Jackson was
gonna start yeah I would watch the Raven
as you would it's hard to watch the
Ravens they have not had a dynamic
player on offense in years yeah and
that's been their problem on that side
of the ball
I got a scenario for you what is it
Urban Meyer steps down mm-hmm John
Harbaugh takes over the Ohio State are
you saying that just to piss me off I
don't have sources close to me telling
me that would never do that he would
never do that he'd get a job in the NFL
in two seconds flat
well I know he could get a job I don't
think he wants to go to college let
alone the Ohio State University I'm sure
they've have about 15 people who would
line up from from their own history to
get somebody from something he's such a
buzzkill like just you know have some
fun I mean if anybody is killing
anybody's buzz right now I think you're
killing mine why Menno an Ohio State you
know fan now are you are you still so
one when it comes down to that game on
so it doesn't hurt me but you would be
you're sitting down you'd prefer to see
Ohio State win because I know you're
special you're professional it's not the
best story so Michigan beating Ohio
State's the better stone what's the
better story out of tonight's Thursday
Night Football game if Green Bay wins
see I'd go the other way around
why Green Bay loses oh okay
so not see how two wins but Green Bay
loses that would be yes that would be
the look the the concept of what you
were talking about I heard driving in
the most passive-aggressive relationship
in the NFL right now
is Aaron Rodgers towards his coach I
mean there's no there's no two ways
about it anybody who's been in a
passive-aggressive relationship in any
part of your life will see what Aaron
Rodgers is saying from the podium every
now and then about his coach and so if
they lose to go to for five and one
I think Rodgers would be in a position
where we'll hear is latest version of
relax or I've got this and potentially
go on some sort of tear I think that
that to save yet another season and
potentially McCarthy even staying there
that can't happen
McCarthy staying there right can I think
this is the end to it can't but how did
they allow this to get to this point
rich there was no secret of there was
some kind of discourse there was a
disconnect between these two and that
you allow this to go into the season and
it didn't take long before Rodgers is
rolling his eyes I don't know I think if
I'd have I know him to use the parlance
of sports talk radio point the finger
the finger of blame it would have to be
Ted Thompson who just you know was mr.
Groundhog Day just ran everything back
every single year under the same concept
and now there's a new general manager
there and Brian Goethe Kunz Tim we'll
see if that changes anything getting his
quote unquote guy in there after a dozen
years it's been a long time that they
have been there I mean it was funny have
you had Greg Jennings on your show have
you had him no you gotta get him on he's
great
I mean we had him on a couple weeks ago
just talking about his history with the
Packers and his his take on this
situation is is pretty damn good and he
was telling stories that right that
McCarthy was there from the Favre to
Rodgers transition that's been forever
in a day since they did all of that and
you know told a story about how you know
Favre would hear McCarthy call a play
and his in his ear and they'd hear it in
the huddle and change it any change it
he said yeah we're not doing that play
and he thinks that Aaron Rodgers doing
the same thing right now
it really is we'll see what happens
tonight so that's to me I think on the
interesting
and Seattle needs it more I really think
because Seattle is in a division where
they're not gonna be able to win it so
that wildcard they got to be the best
they possibly can
Rogers can go for five and one rip off
five of the next six and maybe get nine
wins anyway yeah just trying to figure
this out now where teams are headed in
like the Giants are the Giants should
they want to win try to win uh I think
the Raiders are showing what you should
do right now and I think the Jets should
do the same damn thing right now but the
guy you know that the the issue is you
can't really tank in the NFL by the fact
that guys when they put their helmets on
their pads on their shoes on they're not
going out to to you know lose and
coaches aren't gonna do that either but
if you pair the roster down as much as
the Raiders have right now then you
really don't have much of a chance
anyway and the tent folds up in the
second or third quarter is it well this
a front office tanking is what it is
with with the Raiders it's just like the
Marlins you know Derek Jeter took
offense when Bryant Gumbel said you know
you're tanking he goes no no those you
know with the product we've they're
playing hard out there no it's what you
put out exactly that's where it's
front-office
thank you and the Raiders sending Bruce
Irvin packing I mean the number of
players that they've sent packing for
whatever reason because they're not one
of their type of players or they're not
you know part of the future I mean the
Bruce Irvin cut I mean especially from a
coach that had been lamenting about the
lack of pass rush since he didn't hook
keep of Khalil Mack I mean it really is
something else so with the Giants it's a
different story though they've got a new
head coach who doesn't have nine more
years left on his contract like the one
like Gruden and they have also a legacy
quarterback and a dynamic offense that
should be winning more than most so uh
as well well yes it would behoove them
to have a higher draft pick for their
future I think that they're not in that
position yes yes McLovin but question
for both guys is it worth tanking if you
don't need a quarterback or if there's
not the obvious quarterback like do
you'd like the Raiders if they want to
keep card do they need to tank or well I
mean I think that's the third rail
ultimate subject with the Raiders is
what does Gruden really think of of car
it all comes down to it I can't see him
as his quarterback when they get
Vegas so he's got a huge ass contract
too so I don't know who's gonna acquire
it what they're gonna do who they're
gonna who they're gonna who what what
they would do with Derek Carr so I
almost went David I was him and I do
that every damn time so he that's the
ultimate is what want will Gruden think
he's gonna have three potentially top 20
draft choices right now it's one and 12
and 23 right now with the Bears being
the one congratulations Paulie
being the one that is the worst of the
first round draft choices feeling good
are you really not really no I think
we're one and done in the playoffs
playoff team you get on a pose Enfield's
and they'll get exposed that would
that's all you need this year anyway
yeah if I told you they were gonna make
the playoffs this year you would have
said Ben sign me up
even if you're gonna be one and done no
doubt true Brisky feels like a good NFL
quarterback definitely out of that
busted zone I think that's fair well it
clearly what you know the Rams did with
Sean McVeigh and then the Bears did with
with naggy you know take a young coffin
civ minded coach and put him to the hip
of your second year quarterback and
let's see what flies that is in this
copycat league what I think everybody's
gonna try and do as well maybe the Jets
would Sam darn 'old we'll see what
happens with Dallas you know well that's
another thing yeah I'm talking to rich
eyes and NFL Network host the situation
with the Cowboys and you start with
Jerry Jones with Jason Garrett like at
some point does Jerry just admit you
know what I made a mistake here or
keeping Jason is not the right guy or do
you think man I cuz it's the Jerry Jerry
doesn't admit to mistakes very often but
it just feels like he's compounding this
and I do believe dak Prescott is
attached to Jason Garrett as well so if
you change your coach right well they're
gonna have to decide on whether to give
dak that second contract or not the next
year pretty much and so would you I
would not I would not you don't think
he's the franchise would you give him a
fifty sixty million dollars seventy
eighty million dollar contract
I wouldn't I you know I wouldn't
certainly in this day and age where you
go find your next one and go five years
a problem with the Dallas Cowboys is
that they've made so much other mistakes
like Romo I think is still dead money on
their cap right now now is the time when
you've got a guy who's not he's on his
first contract build around like the
Russell Wilson plan the one that
obviously the Rams are on right now and
the Eagles are on right now and then
you're able to win now like that's the
idea now go ahead and do that again
certainly since the one thing you do
have to point out what Jerry is the guys
that he's been drafting lately more
often than not or panning out I mean
Byron Jones
Jaylon Smith everybody blew him up the
guy is just sideline to sideline a
monster van Dhiresh instead of Calvin
Ridley everybody blew him up on that
we'll see if amare Cooper's worth the
one but he's really running routes well
I can't imagine if that guy was running
routes like that in Oakland where was he
the last two years so we'll see what
happens over the next few weeks they I
think they should win this game in
Atlanta they then have two games at home
on Thanksgiving and then a week later
against two NFC South opponents I mean
against the Washington Redskins and then
the Saints who I think you know they're
the frontrunners right now at the NFC
and I picked the Rams to win the Super
Bowl before the season yeah but that's
there's still a lot of football I know
if I said Chiefs Rams Saints you could
have to yeah can I choose the Rams in
the Saints you think those are the two
best teams yeah I do I just need to
switch defensively where's Kansas City
in the pantheon of AFC title contenders
number one do you think they're the best
team in the amps I do I do okay because
I needed with the Patriots lately I
think they would have trouble going
point for point that forty three thirty
forty result I think would be different
right now I don't know what's going on
with Gronk I don't know what's going on
offensively that they're not putting up
as many points right now so if they had
to play again I think it'd be a
different result Pittsburgh is playing
better and I think you know that levee
on not coming back might be good for the
locker room was that stuff I need to
know this for my show later was that
stuff
pulling from his locker fake are they
trying to pass that off as fake that
they were that they were yanking the
chain of the media in there or when I
was right I got the impression that they
were being cute that I could actually
steal their former steal his sneakers I
was gonna ask you about that when I saw
it and you would have thought that just
out of respect they'd say hey here's
your gear it seemed like it was a bit
that the you know the Steeler players
were going a early Christmas here and
they were joking to the camera I'm
telling you the one thing one of the
many things but this is a top five
things I don't understand from fan bases
in the NFL is the Mike Tomlin hate in
Pittsburgh that people would just like
there are some Steeler fans like just to
get rid of him he doesn't you know well
I mean I hear that because they don't
beat the Patriots year in and year out
that they're not as dominant in the AFC
year in and year out as the Patriots
they lost against the Patriots this year
if they lose again in week 15 you'll
hear it again
but there is an iceberg in Pittsburgh
and we see just the tip of it I mean
just the tip of it the other day when
when Tomlin was asked about levy on bail
for the umpteenth time the day or two
days before he was slated to either come
back or not know for the rest of the
year
Tomlin's like you know I got you know I
got a locker room a guys and I'm worried
on right now which is you know a great
way of using the coaching cliche if I
can control only where they can control
and I'm only coaching the guys who are
here and so I'm like saying as well like
he could have easily finished a sentence
saying did you not see Antonio Brown go
clock a hundred in his Batmobile the
other day on the day of the game against
Carolina did you not see you know my
quarterback who is an all-world first
ballot hall-of-famer but is also a
hall-of-famer
in terms of saying one sentence to many
every time there's a microphone in front
of him and that's two important guys
here I mean we could go on and on and on
so the locker room that decides the day
left bells not coming back let's either
raid his locker for fun or raid his
locker for real it's a reason why I
don't put Pittsburgh
I guess up with Kansas City right now
Kansas City you know you know I know
usually losses to Pittsburgh
head-to-head but not with this kid
mahomes it's I he's a total difference
maker yeah I just think people look at
Mike Tomlin and you know does he
coach you but does he win games where he
out coaches somebody and I think that's
the knock on him and also the locker
room there's always drama in that locker
room always right more than anybody else
and the drama gets out of the locker
room more than anybody else so I have to
hold him accountable for some Jordan why
can't we say that Tomlin outcoached Ron
Rivera this past week just because they
put a 52 and that's not his side of the
ball you know big game I mean in a big
game but I mean again like Antonio Brown
clocked whose job is it to tell hey
coach look I know you're not on Twitter
but guess what did he may be a B a B as
this Batmobile and he went a hundred and
forty mile an hour zone like whose job
is it to tell Tomlin that and then he
figures it out
I just he figures it out and so many
teams don't year in and year out but you
know I guess we'll see I do you have any
advice for a Fritzie you being a
stand-up comedian I'm so proud of you
for doing that I appreciate that you are
welcome this very scary um you know I've
I've heard the critique in your
direction
but anybody who listens to the show
knows you use way too many words to get
to the point and then once you make the
point you use way too many words to get
out of the story which is an absolute
handicap for a stand-up comedian so but
he's very proud of me of words is a
three point I would make to you not only
because it's an it's important for a
stand-up comedy but just the phrase
itself is an economy of words so it's
easy for you to remember but keep doing
it because you clearly have a passion
for it and it makes everything else in
life easier and you deserve all the
kudos in the world even though I guess I
just sliced you up a little bit it means
a lot too
and the criticism is the constructive
Christmas well taken okay and it is a
frightening thing but as you know you
would never have tried it there's
something really special about going up
then if making people I don't know I
don't know what's a bigger hi than
coming up next on HBO economy of words
the Todd Fritz it's special yes correct
but it's got a catchy title economy of
words well I guess he's right Chris
Mannix said that he's the Sacramento
Kings of stand-up comic what means that
you're on you're on the upside here I
never thought it'd compared the Aaron
Fox Howard Todd no it's special to go up
on stage and make people laugh Wow rich
used to do it Wow I'm just sayin Wow
yeah there was a chuckle or two Monday
night I don't know it's like to be a
running back in the NFL because they
never but I heard that one that the
comedian before you totally died on
stage right that's not good you want I
know that the gain immediate contrast
you'd want to follow some of this
totally kill but you want the audience
to be up in a laughing mood
absolutely yeah you know because it
Caroline's Todd was bookended by two new
comics yeah who crushed or very they
were hilarious oh and Todd was sort of
you didn't get any spillover he did not
get any spillover that momentum did not
carry it was as if the Oreo cookie was
in the middle of the two Oreo happen
right there okay and Rich Eisen show on
DirecTV audience Network channel 239
Ricardo great to see you buddy thank you
for stopping by attention for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]